[Music] I
already had two brothers, one 16 years old and
the other 17 years old.
Whoever went to work wouldn't let my daddy go, they left,
even though he was 17 years old, they raised him
too much when his kidneys had already
advanced the disease,
his kidneys in the  pse they burst
him as long as velez the improvement in my father
he sold everything he
sold the roof he spread everything we would be
left with nothing
if he were alive my father wasn't
working
at the gym
with the same pain as
my brother my 11-year-old brother came back  performing he
also died with the same disease
that I have
and one day I arrived and they pampered me and look how
pale you are and he said oh you berg
the doctor gave me the neurologist you want
dialysis he told me face to face and I
started to cry
and I  I'm already just like my brothers
I tell you
[Music]
we are
visiting you this time to invite you to participate
in a study of what it means to rule out
chronic kidney disease and you
want to participate  if
you get up you do it
today you can eat until 8 at
night
for tomorrow because six of
us do that we take our
blood pressure
tomorrow
but no thanks
[Music]
I'm taking what my dad takes out I don't
take for  selling there I carry mango yucca
my daddy right now is occasional because
since his own doesn't have
[Music]
the first time they performed it shocked me
and at that time I didn't have insurance where they
had dialysis or dialysis
serving a month with portions that I
I went into a coma
the doctor went out to tell all the
blood everyone has come on audio or
dialysis on Thursdays
and
I spoke with the owner of the clinic
he had me a year free in his clinic
you told me that the
state changed
diagnosing his insufficiency  kidney disease was
synonymous with death and health systems
have covered dodd
hemodialysis life expectancy in these patients
has increased
the highest percentage we have in
our environment is due to diabetes and
hypertension  In addition,
a smaller percentage are the
electronic queen diseases of unknown cause.
The region is enduring
higher temperatures compared to previous years.
Most of the people dedicate a lot of
time to physical work
and neglect a lot the part of the
patient's hydration.
against what is renal function
the preventive part promotional of
less cost to appearing in the
recovery phase of treatment
every human being has the right to health
in two weeks the result of this
blood sample arrives at the door of
your house is for  rule out diabetes and
smara rule out creativity that has
to do with renault problems
you are older sometimes having
problems walking
[Music]
at the beginning it shows us symptoms but
when it is in the terminal stage it already
shows the symptoms
what is the purpose of  this study see
the prevalence and cases of kidney disease
[Music]
all these samples are processed here  in
the global health center and they are sent already
processed to lima by means of an ocurriera
ah
[Music]
marí marí
comes sugared
to pillar the average of sugar and
sugar but that's it
pills and pills pills and
pills are no longer me  patient loves
all of the pill
like this when I was just here and my sister
wanted to donate my kidney but I didn't want to
I don't know but because it scares me she
answers that the space
doctor told me nothing is going to happen to them
anymore and that's it  you are worth your
normal life no longer dialysis
better you want to stay idealize but
I am not going to operate
and tonight we ask you holy father
to be you speaking tonight sir
taking control in this place seems to
take control followers inflection you are going to
take control of fatigue you have loved me
that does not lose faith that can
go on you have loved me in the
name of jesus children
no
[Music]
2 I am not 8 years old
the pinion machine I already accepted my
illness and  I'm going to continue with my
illness until when bye-bye day you go
[Music]
when Mr.
d
[Music]
i
y
[Music]